the eight news now investigators are
uncovering more details about the
politician accused of killing journalist
jeff german two years ago robert tellis
faced a domestic violence charge after
police say he grabbed a woman and held
her in a quote bear hug position he was
also accused of refusing to cooperate
with authorities the charges were
dismissed as part of a plea deal after
he attended an online class now these
details surfacing while telus remains in
jail this afternoon 8 news now
investigator vanessa murphy explains why
this current case hasn't moved forward
just yet
robert tellis will remain in jail for
now he's seen here in the courtroom for
about less than a minute with a smile on
his face his lawyer is requesting more
time to work on this murder case while
clark county district attorney steve
wolfson says his prosecutors will
continue to prepare to argue for a
significant bail at the next hearing we
consider him to be a flight risk and a
danger
to the community so when the bail issue
arises we're going to argue for a very
high bail high bail like what i'm not
going to throw a figure out there
but i guarantee you my prosecutors who
are some of the best
are going to argue for a significant
bail tellis is the clark county public
administrator he's accused of killing
review journal investigative journalist
jeff gearman who exposed problems under
the leadership of telus telus then lost
the democratic primary did you do this
did you commit this murder
talis not commenting before his arrest
this was wednesday after metro police
executed a search warrant at his piccoli
ranch home police say they found telus's
dna under the fingernails of german
along with shoes a hat and a vehicle
connected to the crime scene the
evidence at this point is very
compelling
the dna evidence places him with mr
german and there's additional physical
evidence that connects him to this crime
gearman was 69 years old his age as a
senior enhances the murder charge telus
is expected to be back in court on
september 20th no comment from his
attorney travis shetler but he says he
may hold a press conference later this
week reporting in downtown las vegas at
the regional justice center vanessa
murphy 8 news now